the easiest way to move past is to start
to get excited about the future when you
are excited about your future you spend
zero time thinking about all the things
that you did wrong going backwards you
did the best you could with what you had
forgive yourself if you had to do it all
over again you would probably play a
little bit different now because you're
smarter you're wiser you have more
experience but you can't go back in time
and sitting wishing that you could and
all the mistakes that you would have
fixed doesn't serve you so the key is to
start getting excited about the future
don't overlook the process it's small
chunks day by day the consistent daily
habits is what's going to get you there
you can't avoid it you got to go through
it you just have to do it the plan
matters but it does not matter nearly as
much as showing up every single day if
you're reaching out to someone you need
to be able to convey effectively
communicate but them spending time with
you is valuable we're so worried about
trying to be someone that we're not and
who might judge us and who might comment
on your video or whatever it was
something nasty but focus on who you're
serving who you are serving like
somebody needs your message today
what is your advice for success to show
up and keep showing up and show up some
more like
I think the one thing that I've learned
from just interacting with you being
mentored by you having a part of my
businesses the plan
matters but it does not matter nearly as
much as showing up every single day
giving it your all you know executing
something that's a three out of ten
consistently is way better than having a
10 out of 10 that you show up
occasionally like it's you just got to
keep keep going and keep showing up and
even when you question it even when you
don't think it's going to get you there
the habit of consistency will keep doing
the work I love it so advice for success
for me just to Carry On from what Zach
said uh one is believe in the thing that
you're doing believe that the work you
know believe in like actually have
passion for the work that you're doing a
lot of people they just chase down
things because of things they think
they're gonna make a lot of money doing
it but they don't actually love the
thing like the number one most common
bit of success that's come from all the
people that I've profiled and watched
and studies is actually love the thing
you have to have passion for the thing
that you're creating how to be good with
people true interactions uh
vulnerability is always good and don't
peacock too many people try to pretend
there's something else and they get into
like a conversational relationship with
someone and it's nonsense just be who
you truly are so Bo and I start the
business to uh book people onto
different shows interview shows podcasts
or if you have your own show or podcast
and you want guests to come on Bo helps
find people for your show so Beau has
done a lot of the heavy lifting for
bringing on some of the big names on my
channel as well so Bo if you want to
connect
and be good with people who are at a
higher level than you who you might
think the first thing is from you what's
your advice is all the illusion that you
need that social metric or that vanity
metric of ten thousand subs or whatever
to connect with someone so if you're
reaching out to someone you need to be
able to convey effectively communicate
that then spending time with you is is
valuable
uh how you and I met uh five years six
years ago um you saw you saw an
opportunity to add value to what I was
doing you thought it would be good
content for you and that exploded our
relationship so it's about ensuring that
you're not just doing it for the likes
or the metrics it's I can advance a
value transaction so we we've managed to
get like Tony Robbins McConaughey the
biggest names in the world for other
shows that aren't that big because they
see it as a value proposition to
probably express what they want to talk
about where they won't get another
platform for it so that's that's a good
way to do it how did we even meet so
this could be a good story because we
went from I think it was with your two
minute interview but maybe maybe I'm
wrong uh to then go from like meeting
somebody to then starting a business
with each other and and creating a
mid-six figure uh
four minutes four minute Masters
it was like a four minute interview show
um and I thought it was easy to reach
out to people and book people but you
were smart enough to realize that I had
a certain skill and uh we were back and
forth over a few years uh we're always
like just communicating like cordially
was great and then I came and visited
you in Toronto at a uh at one of your
events
um and then we just started chatting and
I started booking people through your
channel because you're like hey look you
can do this Lifting for me I love doing
that that like gets me off that's what I
find fun
and then uh you were walking your dogs
one Saturday during covid and I got a
random uh message like we need to talk I
I know what I know the next chapter for
you and I was like all right and we got
on and like speed is the essence so we
uh we started this agency I think you
messaged me on a Saturday and by Monday
we started we got our first client I
think on Thursday
and from there we have just glued our
foot to the metal and just kept growing
and when you do what you love so much
it's so much fun but we met because I
effectively outreached to you and I feel
like your whole thing's belief and
believe and you saw something in me that
I didn't see in myself at the time and
then when as soon as I saw it as soon as
we joined fourth is we've created a nice
little Empire
so you just randomly emailed me like
that was it I didn't know you there was
yes
was easy so my first four guests were
you Wim Hof Gary vaynerchuk and Mel
Robbins yeah I just to me it's like when
you think something's easy to you it
doesn't matter and then other people
started seeing that as a value commodity
and relationships are such a undersold
soft skill that it was my Michael Jordan
I found that that was what I was good at
I wanted to be a musician or so many
things in my life but I found my lane
and the more I lean into it and double
down through relationships connecting
networking whatever you want to call it
I just call it being human uh it's
really easy okay so being good with
people has has historically been a
challenge for me being shy introverted
um
find it find it hard to start off
conversations but the thing that
actually helped the most
um was actually just be curious about
people
just find a way to be curious about
somebody because I think especially if
you're introvert
uh we don't like having very surface
level conversations
we don't like talking about the weather
we don't like talking but hey how about
that sports team you know it feels fake
and introverts don't like being fake
uh but we love we actually love deep
conversations and so the way to do that
is to start finding one thing that you
can be really curious about the person
if you can generally be curious about
them then it's so much easier to have a
conversation and you're asking questions
about them and people love talking about
themselves so the way to be good with
somebody is just ask some questions but
not that it's leading to a sales pitch
or something that you just genuinely
care about the person and all of a
sudden they're doing most of the talking
and then at the end of it they're saying
wow that person you're such a great
conversationalist I really like talking
with you really was them doing most of
the talking and you asking the questions
but it's got to be questions that you
genuinely are curious about and care
about I find that that really helps me
how to get over someone you love after a
breakup when it still hurts love
yourself more
and
to break up either you initiated if they
step back and say was that really good
for you to stay in it or is it a dinner
up with opportunity for you that you're
out of it to better be able to get in
love with yourself again because I think
a lot of times for myself personally I
can only speak for myself personally a
lot of times we try so hold to hold on
to someone else that we forget about our
sales and we put someone else's
happiness in making them feel good most
of them realizing you know what I've
forgotten about myself and what I really
want so that's that's what I do for
myself is realize I have to love myself
more and sometimes that means I have to
be at peace with the breakup and be as
peaceful being by myself for a while
thank you Sarah so okay my answer uh how
to get over someone that you love after
breakup when it still hurts so whether
it's
um
a breakup in uh in a personal
relationship in a business relationship
you can always think about what you what
you would have done what you should have
done what you could have done looking
backwards but it very rarely serves you
the easiest way to move past is to start
to get excited about the future
when you are excited about your future
you spend zero time thinking about all
the things that you did wrong going
backwards right you did the best you
could with what you had forgive yourself
if you had to do it all over again you
would probably play a little bit
different now because you're smarter
you're wiser you have more experience
but you can't go back in time and and
sitting wishing that you could and all
the mistakes that you would have fixed
doesn't serve you so the key is to start
getting excited about the future
get excited about the future what are
you building what are you creating what
are you moving towards not where you
have come from and where you struggled
and sucked so if it's a business
opportunity get excited about the new
business you're going to make if it's a
relationship
get excited about the next relationship
you're going to have right get on the
get on the different dating apps and see
who's out there see who's on the market
for you right now and get excited like
allow yourself to dream again and to
wish again and to Hope again because
that thing that you came from was not
the one for you anyway you're trying to
move through some past mistakes
you give yourself credit for doing the
best you could with what you had and
then we start getting excited about the
future that is still ahead Adam we got a
question you ready for the question okay
yeah I know you got an answer for this
one how well how to not procrastinate oh
I'll unpack it here Nick just a couple
minutes so how to not procrastinate
really just start
visualize where you want to go find your
why you want to go there and then begin
begin to put in small chunks the process
to get you there and to keep the
promises that you've made to yourself is
the most important thing so
um what do you want to do oh my gosh
Evan you've got me on this one thought
to action thought to action Evan I never
forgot that you actually told me that
just right over there you told me
thought to action that's when I went to
your academy uh in Toronto but so small
chunks and never forget the why
sometimes you need to write it down that
you'll have it in your face so write it
down get to the place a little bit at a
time it's the habitual things sometimes
we get uh you gotta have that future
that bright future the reason why you're
doing something and then it's gonna
start to move forward it'll start to
move but you can't oh don't over don't
um don't overlook the process it's small
chunks day by day the consistent daily
habits is what's going to get you there
so don't lose focus on that and if you
need to look at Evan Carmichael's has
thousands of videos that can keep you on
point so that's one thing get around
people that you kind of you want a role
model you like how does Evan do this all
the time how does he walk in three hours
a day how he goes off to action and
keeps the promises that he makes for
himself and that's how you do something
that's all this whole thing was built
this is why you're impacting so many
people Evan it's thought to action and
keeping the promises that you make to
yourself that's the most important thing
in getting around other people if you're
you hang around five Stanford um
Stanford University livestaff or grads
you'll become the sixth be careful fool
you around be careful watching you what
you're hearing and always keep the
promises that you make to yourself and
you'll get it done believe me my book is
called live life on purpose from running
the streets to running a beat get your
copy now from Amazon it's everywhere
Gotta Love Adam Durant you never know
who you're gonna meet when you join
these lives which is which is great I
love it okay let me answer this and
we'll move on to the next one uh how to
not procrastinate best way I found is
you create a calendar so you create a
calendar and you put in your calendar
the habits that will lead you towards
success right so
you have ideas for what you want to
create amazing none of that happens
until you create into actions right it's
the actions and the habits that you do
every day that lead you towards your
dreams otherwise it just remains hopes
and dreams
so this would not be happening if it was
on my calendar right I had to schedule
this in I want to walk outside for three
hours a day great
well when is that going to start
if you don't if I did not put in my
calendar I would not be out here doing
this
and so step one is you create a calendar
that maps to your Ambitions that are the
habits that if you follow those habits
you have moved closer to your goals your
business goals your personal goals your
relationship goals your Finance goals
are you doing the work is it in your
calendar right step one and then step
two is you teach yourself that you do
what's in your calendar
that we're eliminating the thought
process behind it because
procrastination is your brain gets in
the way
right your brain is telling you oh I'll
do it later I can't do it now I'm not
smart enough or I I need to do some
research first like your brain gets in
the way so the way to shortcut the brain
is you create the calendar and then you
do what's in your calendar
so you create the calendar when you're
feeling bold and courageous and you know
you come with a new goal it's like so
exciting great don't just sit in that
excitement and not just go researching
plop in your calendar how you're going
to keep this consistently happening in
your life so that you don't just get
this momentarily burst of energy and
then you fall back down
right so you put it in your calendar how
you're going to sustain this action how
I got this I was at an event uh two
weeks ago and I got this idea that I'm
going to start walking outside and it
started off as two hours a day then last
it became three hours a day this week
continuing to three hours a day
it's great to get an idea out of how
many times you got an idea at an event
or watching a video you get some great
idea awesome if you just do it once it's
not enough how do you maintain the
consistency how do you turn into a habit
don't wait for you to feel motivated it
has to go into your calendar so I pop
this into my calendar and then when I
wake up and I look at my calendar I do
it to my calendar
so you eliminate the brain from the
process and therefore eliminating the
procrastination so you create your
calendar when you're feeling bold and
courageous and on top of the world and
Unstoppable maybe like right now you're
getting some energy go put something in
your calendar and then when you wake up
you do what's in your calendar do those
two things it'll change your life how do
you manage a slow staff in retail
setting that requires speed to attend
the customers ooh what I've learned from
you is to train the people
is to find people who have the
if you're at the beginning and you're
still trying to get the people in then
it's fine the people who have the the
attitudes the heart that you want and
then you train them to do the thing that
you want them to do if it's people that
are already there I think it comes back
to what you do on Mondays it's mentoring
like what is it you want to see them do
how can you help them in order to be
able to do that thing that you want them
to be doing so I just going through a
process now bringing new people on to
her team and mentoring and training how
is that going and what lessons have you
learned finding people training people
to do what you do that's the first thing
I learned
second thing is the skills are easy to
teach but it's it's the harder part is
getting people to
want it not like wanted as much as you
do but kind of
so here's what I've rehearsal process
that I took and I learned it from you
right I gave the people that I'm
training I gave them a couple of books
reading materials to say okay go through
this thing and in in this amount of
crime say two weeks go through it and
when you're done in that time then we're
gonna take it to the next level
and so it got to a point for me where
it's like do I just forget the fact that
he didn't get to do the thing that I
asked them to do I'll move on to the
next level or should I stick to my guns
and say hey we agreed you were going to
do this thing you haven't done it so I'm
holding
you finish
part in order to move to the next level
so I think it comes down to you as a
leader if you and the team have set up
or set up a plan to say this is what
we're going to do
okay so when you're managing the team
there are two different things that you
need to manage first is values and the
second is skill set
values are a lot a lot a lot harder to
shift than skill set so
quite often with something like this is
it that they just don't value customer
service they don't they don't value the
customers coming in they don't care
about people they're not uh friendly
people or is that they don't know how to
respond
so this is something I'm training Nina
my wife on because she's now we've got
50 people on the team and Nina is now
responsible for hiring most of the new
people on the team and managing most of
the people on the team and she's
first time managing people and obviously
customer support is one of those things
that is really important and so as she's
managing a team when there's a problem
when they don't get something done when
you know they promise they would but
they don't before automatically judging
and blaming them it's asking okay is it
a values thing
or a skill thing did we do our part did
we train them enough were we clear
enough because we might say well if they
don't understand they should ask
questions but they don't always ask
questions a lot of people are afraid to
ask questions uh even especially at the
beginning of a new job they're afraid to
ask questions so is it that they didn't
understand it is it that we weren't very
clear is it that we didn't give them the
tools to set them up for success is it a
training issue is it on us to be better
or
is it just that they don't care about
this that's uh
intuitive thing that you have to figure
out because if you just looked at the
black and white and said well they
didn't get it done the people why didn't
they get it done and how much of that is
on us now people ultimately show you who
they are
you know if I'd has given people a book
to go and read and they promise they're
going to read it and they don't in the
first week okay could there be a reason
could it could have been could it have
been Ida's fault was it clear that they
had to read it uh in a week right
um was it did they you know was it out
of stock or out of print were there some
issues you know in getting it but if
it's a continual thing you know people
will show you who they are where they
always have an excuse for everything
then okay at some point it's not your
fault anymore it's theirs but the the
question becomes how do you get there
faster
how to decide that faster
and generally wanting your team to win
you know especially if it's a skills
thing and it's a value thing it's like
they're just better off somewhere else
they're better off not being in a
position if they don't value helping
people then don't put them in a customer
service role because
training them to be better at the skill
won't make any difference if they just
don't love the thing if it's not
naturally in them if you have to retrain
their value system it's just not worth
the effort they're better off somewhere
else and you're better off with someone
else too but just use that as your
filter because
this is a big problem for entrepreneurs
we tend to think that we we very clearly
explain something because in our heads
it's a problem in our head is very clear
in our head here's what I want
but
your team is not in your head they often
will need you to go deeper and explain
more and especially at the beginning of
relationship they may not ask the
questions that they need to ask or they
may not even thought of the right
question to ask until later
so uh I'll usually default to say hey
did we do something wrong did we not
explain it
but then yeah people will ultimately
show you who they are but just if you
catch it faster you can make progress
faster too
how do you sell your product or promote
yourself without sounding egotistical
that's a good one so listen we got a
question here I thought you could answer
it you're all about greatness so helping
people unlock their greatness yeah
about how are you serving the other
person and ultimately set an objective
about what you know what what are you
aiming for the other person to get from
the transit so I think I think if you're
always thinking about how do you add
value are you literally solving a
problem and does your solution
um you know deliver around its promise I
think starting with those type of
um you know points will really set you
in in the right way so yeah just being
of service man just like you promote
that always being authentic
um and then also like you know probably
speaking to the prospect about what
happens when they come aboard asthma
because preempting um objections about
you know for example if I if I deal with
you are you just going to leave me alone
or do you give me customers customer
support so those type of things
um can really help to instill Trust
podcast is called unless you're in the
greatness and it'd be awesome if you can
listen to Evan's um yeah segment with us
because it was really powerful yeah
Joseph it was a fun episode and I
thought he could bring some value to
this question as well so great to see
you man the easiest way that I found to
to promote and not something egotistical
is to tell stories
so I struggle with this a lot struggling
to charge my money for what I did
struggling to believe in the price tag
that I was charging so I'm going to
increase the price and I found out that
I was like I'm doing all this work
for almost no money and
it just wasn't it wasn't working out
right it's like okay I need to find a
way to be able to sell my products and
services without it
you know I need to make money you know
and how do I do it without it being in a
super slimy way and So Stories was one
of the things that seemed me the most
um of course serving right so it's a
great message I wrote the book built to
serve there's lots in there and an easy
way to do is through your stories
so whether it's your story or a customer
story or
um something that you've helped right if
so you know case study I don't know what
you're selling but if somebody comes in
and says hey I'm struggling with I'm
struggling with YouTube all right I'm
starting with YouTube you don't have to
go don't have to do my thumbnails I
don't know we're not growing we're not
getting the results we want how do I go
on YouTube instead of just saying well I
have this service and you can go hire uh
Zach to help you on this and it's going
to cost you blank right that feels super
slimy want to get to know them better
it's like well tell me tell me about
what you're selling what you're trying
to create what your goals are
and then I'll usually tell some kind of
story
so a story about other people that we've
helped or a story I usually don't use
exact names at people but you could if
you have their permission and I'll tell
a story of somebody like them and how
they achieve results and ultimately what
ends up happening is they come back and
say wow if that person can do it you
know maybe I can too how do I work with
you
and so it's much more consultative where
you're asking questions and really
deeply I think this is where you'll
probably win if you feel like sales is
too slimy and it sounds too egotistical
awesome make it about them
make it about your clients deeply
understand you know the people who are
who are massive egotistical don't ask
questions about the prospect they don't
ask questions about the client they're
just trying to sell sell sell ask
questions get to know them understand
what they're actually going through and
why they're talking to you in the first
place what are their problems and then
tell stories around how you can how you
have solved it for other people
and I found that just be an easy way to
get people
to take the right action it's not always
the best thing to work with you
but when it is they want to sign on
because they love the stories that you
shared and that you took the time to
listen how to avoid the Imposter
syndrome effect ooh if you don't know
Angela she goes live a lot to asking
people to tell their stories reminding
people that we're all just humans and a
lot of times and just having
I mean there's people coming online
they're nervous to talk to you they're
scared they're going live who's going to
see this a bunch of people having
posture syndrome
um I know you struggled with that a
little bit at the beginning and getting
your show off the ground too so
to this question to just one victory
the best advice that Evan has ever
shared with me and has helped me so much
is that you can't avoid it you got to go
through it I mean you just have to do it
um and feel what it feels like to do it
and then you recognize what that feeling
feels like and then the next time you do
it you'll have have a better
understanding of what to do with it
um and just be present I think that's
for me just you know
um it's not easy to show up especially
you feel like you're in your head when
you're in your head but if you get in
your heart
um and you remember why you're doing it
in the first place and stay in your
heart then that let your heart guide you
and that's been the that's been the most
helpful for me okay my answer it's for
imposter syndrome honestly um there's
two things that I'll do one is remember
who you're focused on serving right
we're so worried about trying to be
someone that we're not and who might
judge us and who might comment on your
video or whatever it was something nasty
uh but focus on who you're serving who
you are serving like somebody needs your
message today
you've got a message you've been through
something you have advice to share
somebody needs that and focus on who
that person is and it may not be a
million people it may just be eight
people who watch your video but for one
person that might be a life like your
message might be the life-changing
message that they need today and so
focus on that when you're out there
creating and two the other thing I find
helpful is imagine you're talking to
younger you
so
when we get stuck in imposter syndrome
we think of oh if you look at Angela
who's hosting her own show like well but
I'm not Larry King or I'm not Oprah or
I'm not whoever and we let that be the
reason why we don't start
whereas think about who you used to be
so for me the most painful point in my
life was 19 when I quit on my business
partner and so I go back to think can I
help 19 year old Evan
if I was gonna sit on a park bench and
talk to 19 year 11 would I have
something that I could say and yeah of
course of course I could help I may not
believe I can help a million people but
I believe I can help younger me and say
things for you you may not feel like you
can help tons of people your imposter
syndrome about that but if you think
back to who you used to be think about
who you were five years ago you from
five years ago would listen to you today
and they may not listen to Evan
Carmichael or Oprah or whoever but
they'll listen to you
and so
if you can have a message for younger
you well there's millions of people who
currently are younger you and they're
struggling
and they need you
and just I don't know just the way that
that is framed
for me gets me out of my way
and forces me to get into action mode
they're both an angle of service you
know I'm always going to lean on service
one is you're thinking about the people
who you can help and two as you think
back to younger you and recognize that
you could help younger you and there are
millions of people right now who are
younger you
and they need your help
so it's time to go through
if you were starting today right now and
you were to launch into the thought
leadership business and your goal was to
get to twenty thousand dollars a month
in Revenue what you would do for
yourself if you were getting back into
it uh and you were willing and you're
willing to take massive and Extreme
Action I go a little crazy compared to
most so great first thing if you want to
get the 20 cam month is understand what
are we selling for people that are that
have addiction issues that want to quit
and don't know how so back out twenty
thousand dollars a month for one-on-one
coaching what are we doing are we are we
having 20 people who are giving you a
thousand bucks a month are we doing 40
at 500 we're doing 10 at 4 000 like what
are you what do you want to be doing my
target is to higher level entrepreneurs
and CEO types like that's what I want to
work with that's kind of people that I
want to to help and so my price points
you know closer to five thousand a month
you want to do five thousand dollars a
month that's what you're gonna sell so
you need four people at a time right I
mean if you're if you say that you're
going to help them inside three months
then every three months we need to bring
in four new people the strategy changes
depending on what we're selling at what
price point who we're targeting all that
stuff if I was talking to an audience to
be a different message and if I'm
talking to Jim who has a specific
question right so we want to sell five
thousand dollar coaching packages and we
need four of them to get started so
you're 20K a month Benchmark great the
next question asked is who are the
people who can refer you
to these five thousand dollars
other people that are in the industry if
it's entrepreneurs I guess like that's
like when I put together an interview
list it's it's entrepreneurs right
because if people that listen to other
entrepreneurs that are in the position
that need help from somebody like me so
more specifically like if somebody is an
addict so entrepreneurs are your clients
which is great who are the referral
Partners to your clients so clients will
help refer other clients for sure but
that takes a while to build up for you
to build your reputation to get results
right if somebody then
ultimately in a service-based business
like this if you go in and you help
somebody they get clean they're going to
tell their friends and someone they're
going to want to go sign up with you to
you know solve their problems too but
that's not a that kind of referral based
marketing is not to the spirit of your
question of how do we get 20K a month as
fast as possible right that's not as
fast as possible because you got to go
solve their problem before they're going
to tell people about you so instead of
thinking about our customers who are the
people who can refer us to potential
customers so we're trying to Target
entrepreneurs high level entrepreneurs
slash Executives Executives too you know
they don't want to get out of their
day-to-day life they want to stay with
what they're doing their bad habits
restructure
okay so where are they going these
high-level entrepreneurs Executives who
are struggling with addiction right now
and the things that they're going to
like AAA or whatever just aren't working
for them
who are they telling where are they
going people don't tell anybody they're
hiding it because they're they're
embarrassed because they're successful
in their own right financially they have
businesses that do well and they they
don't know how to get out of this thing
and it's you know it's it's easy stuff
for somebody looking down but they just
can't figure out how to get out of it
and so a lot of times they don't that's
the that's the challenging part and
that's why I was thinking going down
just to entrepreneurs and interview you
know interviewing them or getting
interviewed by you know uh
entrepreneurial podcasts uh to find
people that are hiding because that's
the thing is a lot of them are hiding
and again that's a great strategy for
longer term clients so you make content
you talk about addiction you talk about
the impact in entrepreneurship you make
specific uh pieces of content to help
Executives and entrepreneurs overcome
addiction and whatever methodology that
that you believe in uh that you find
works but that's not a again extreme
twenty thousand dollars a month as soon
as possible strategy that's our build
the brand become the face for on
addiction and America long-term play
so who are they going to who who is the
first person that they do talk to who is
it that notices is it their Doctor Who
then they run some crazy blood tests
something's way off a guy reached out to
for some he's a marketing guy that I
from a past life I reached out to him to
help me find a guy a copywriter to
writes a sales page and he ends up
telling me a week after what you're
going back and forth because he put up
on Facebook for me that he needs to quit
drinking and can I help him and uh it
was because he went to his doctor and
his doctor said his liver was shot
so that actually is a great Insight
right there okay so it could be the the
healthcare professionals
um doctors in in home uh like anybody
who's doing in-home where they get that
person to come visit them uh and they
the doctor would tell them what you know
your your liver is shot so what what's
the next step
unbelievable because also you know a lot
of guys I know have the IVs brought to
their office like guys I know that you
know that high level guys that drink a
lot they're like oh yeah I got an iv in
me right now just because I did all my
vitamins I know they've been drinking
for freaking you know all weekend and
that's what it's actually giving them
the nutrients they need so that the in
in office in homes that is something to
Target 100 that is uh but it would also
take their clients away you know if I
think about it potentially
um
well possibly but
if the client died
the guy is crazy guy I reached out to
you said his doctor said he has to quit
drinking or he's going to die quickly
when people are coming in house and
doing IVs it the IV business doesn't go
away if the person stops becoming
alcoholic they still need IVs it just
changes up but they're going to get
their IDs for because now they're
getting different vitamins put in or
they're doing NAD are they doing
oxygenation of their blood or whatever
right so those are the people that you
want to get to know I mean I just came I
had the Super Bowl I'm in Arizona Super
Bowl's here I got invited to this
high-end Super Bowl party uh on the
weekend and it's all you can eat all you
can drink and it's mostly drinks like
they ran out of food in the first hour
and it's just all tequila and margaritas
and beers and just and like barely any
water and no food so you can imagine in
this in the hot Arizona you know Sun
yeah it's just and then they had a dozen
IV stations things that were being
filled out for people who are getting
like passing out uh and so like okay
let's hook them up and get somebody
Pockets so they can go back
crazy crazy crazy
uh uh anyway that's not usually my
scenes I'm not used to that but that's
crazy so those guys especially the ones
who go to visit because the people who
don't have a lot of money they'll go to
the doctor's office
uh and they'll stand in line and all of
this stuff the people who have money
don't they value their time so it's the
people that they'll come to them or
private clinics
and you know I just went and got the uh
MRT test I don't even know what the MRT
test is uh for what you're allergic to
it all that stuff
yeah like what food causes inflammation
so like
uh later this week like end of the week
probably or Monday next week but
basically like spinach might cause
inflammation for you but it's great for
me that kind of stuff so you get to know
what inflammation what foods cause
inflammation right so you look at the
people who are very likely he will have
the same problems that you have later in
life so make sure he's aware of whatever
your test results are
for sure yeah we can start cutting that
stuff out right away no for sure
um but thank you thank you for the
thought appreciate it
um but those those labs where you go and
you and you get that stuff done that's
not a cheap thing to do uh we did the
MRT then we did the Zoomer test and each
one was like about a thousand five
hundred bucks
usually but then all the individual
Zoomers is a second test with all the
Zoomers that test for like wheat allergy
and uh all this other stuff that like
each one that you want to test for and
we did 13
something and then anyway and the
classes go insane
um but that's that's like that's normal
like people are trying to figure out how
to hack their longevity and so those are
the people that you want to talk you
don't want to talk to the average
everyday general practitioner who's seen
you know people coming in uh with an
allergy or something or they or they
fell and they scratch their knee or they
have an ear infection or like not those
people because those people who are
saying it like at the beginning of the
business ultimately Jim I know you want
to help everybody like addiction is not
just a a wealthy person problem it's a
it's a everybody problem but in order to
get to the point where you can actually
go and have the global impact you have
to be making money doing the thing that
you're doing and so you start back to
the spirit of your question I need to
make twenty thousand dollars as quickly
as possible okay so you want four people
gonna pay you five thousand dollars a
month that's somebody who's got a lot of
money like most people aren't just
dropping 5K a month on coaching right so
but for some people 5 000 a month that's
nothing if you can solve like this is
their this is their biggest problem
right
so those are the people that Target
right those are the people who need to
know your name and can you target
anybody in America or you've got to like
go visit them in person part of it is
like the the end of the program is 30 30
grand for three months and I plan to be
like as soon as they sign up I scheduled
to go see them in the first seven days
like face to face let's get this thing
done okay but your chapter like you can
hit anybody in America and that gets
added to the price by the way too like
your flight
for three months that was included I
would pay for all my own travel out of
that
oh I see okay so you have a 10 5 000
extra to cover your your perfect great
uh
so yeah so uh it opens up your Market it
opens up your Market to all of America
instead of having like Chicago is a big
city lots of people who need help and
again you only you only need four people
this is not like we're trying to get a
million people into this program there
are four people in Chicago who you can
do this for but if somebody wants to
sign up from New York or California or
whatever cool you can go there too uh so
you look at all the people who are
offering these crazy high-end tests and
all the people who are offering all the
crazy high-end Diagnostics
um and then the people who are training
and Consulting on the on the solution
what's the diet that then after I do my
MRT and get the results so what's my
diet going to be for the next three
weeks because those people don't deal
with addiction
like they can say
Okay evan uh MRT diet
uh no caffeine for the next three weeks
maybe maybe I'm like super addicted to
caffeine and if I don't have caffeine
then I'm gonna go smoke up or drink
alcohol or whatever like you can have
the plan cool but if they have an
addiction problem you just given me a
plan as a nutritionist it's not going to
help me solve my problem we're all
addicted it's the right plan it's not
just like opioids I mean there's sugar
it's caffeine oil so the the person can
give me the advice say here's your plan
but I'm not going to stick to it if I
have an addiction problem and that
person doesn't know how to handle
somebody with an addiction problem
that's where they say well let's call
Jim yeah Jim's a guy they got to come in
and help contacting these people has
been this is fantastic
[Music]
so your show then become now is like how
do we build a yeah
is yeah yeah so that's your shows like
you interview those people you interview
the people who can pass referrals to you
so all of the people doing all these
high-end Diagnostics and tests where it
costs thousands of dollars just to do
one test those are the people who you
need to know and they need to know you
and the great thing is nobody's asking
them to do interviews I was just
thinking it's fantastic
so you don't need you can you could be
you could be a brand new channel like it
doesn't matter if you haven't posted any
content yet you're starting a new
channel talking about uh Peak
Performance
and and also addiction and how that
plays a role and by the way a lot of the
most I mean not that you obviously know
this but a lot of the highest level Peak
performers are also massive addicts
um
uh celebrity I mean there's people all
over the place I mean my interview list
I have you know probably 100 people out
that I'm gonna reach out to they're high
level people I don't know if I'll get
them or not but I I
extremely aggressive when it comes to
stuff like that just like when you were
trying to get a hold of um uh Howard um
Starbucks yeah
Starbucks yeah I will get a hold of
those people I will I will interview
them it might be taking a year but I
will interview them so like oh agents
yeah yeah Sports agents like
think about sports like again like who
are we trying to Target and then who can
take you to those people so if if you're
going to be the guy for athletes
athletes I mean look it's it's in the
sports agent's best interest that their
athlete clients are not stuck in
addiction mode because they need to go
perform at the Super Bowl and they're
out getting drunk at a party right
how many athletes have careers have been
destroyed by addiction researching it's
like it's unbelievable it's unreal how
many guys mess their stuff up from from
drugs
and this and there's a lot that just
never never hits public news too
um so those guys right so if you want to
Target athletes we're talking to uh the
agents if you want to Target the
executives and the entrepreneurs we're
talking to the people who are doing the
high-end diagnostic MRT genetic testing
Etc and you have them on your show
you're talking about Peak Performance
and addiction and ideally you go see
them
I ideally you can do it in person you
could start in Chicago it's already a
big enough City big enough market but if
some it's a some high-end specialist
who's in Miami maybe make a trip for the
interview because the point of the
interview isn't to get content the point
of the interview is to build a
relationship quick quick about that
about not spending money so when you're
talking because I mean like yeah I gotta
bring a camera crew I gotta I gotta do
something for that right like what do
you recommend
sure
if you're going to start again like
um how aggressive are we going to get in
our 20 000 a month goal if you don't
want to spend anything then you do it
through Zoom everybody's set up on Zoom
and you spend an hour with them on a
zoom call and you you put up the video
on your your brand new YouTube channel
talking about performance and addiction
as soon as you start getting in one
client then the next one you go meet in
person or you pick people who are in
Chicago who you can go and meet in
person what do you shoot the video you
shoot a video right like I've always
been shooting a video yeah you want to
shoot a video so if it's if it's remote
you do it through Zoom if it's in person
then you could you could hire somebody
to come and shoot with you or you're
going to be resourceful you find
somebody who's got a production company
who has an addiction problem and you
trade Services that's genius they don't
have to find that but I will work on it
but that's not hard too you message
you look up Chicago
videographers and you find or you're you
have an assistant or you just hustle it
out yourself you find 200 people in the
Chicago area who do Video Production
Services right there's a lot and then
you message them and say hey I'm Jim I'm
a leading expert on addiction and I'm
starting this new show and I'm looking
at the trade services for I will help
you stop your addiction to sugar alcohol
drugs or whatever it is and I'm looking
for someone to come and help film me as
I go interview some of the leading
experts on high performance and
addiction in the country and you send
that out 200 times are you gonna get
somebody who says help me
yeah yeah that's good if you want that
crazy like that's that's doable you
message 200 people one of them's gonna
say I mean you'll probably get more than
one you get the pick how many people who
own their own video production companies
also have some kind of addiction problem
and would love to lose weight or fix
their business or fix their relationship
because of the addiction they have to
whatever
sixty percent
of course it's 40 40 are obese so it's
not difficult The Exchange is not even
close like if you were to hire somebody
to come in and film you for the day yeah
if it's one person I know that could be
300 bucks 500 bucks 800 bucks like
you're not spending 5 000 bucks on one
person to come and film you for an
interview and that can even be multiple
camera setup right so for you to coach
them
you're giving them monetarily a much
bigger value than they're giving back
and you're changing their life
um
so yeah
it's an easy hand invaluable thank you
this is fantastic I I I have so many
questions and I don't know so that's how
you get your crew this is just a state
on the one thing because you're a stud
and it's awesome so thank you so much
man you can rinse and repeat for
anywhere
you know like if you again you wanna if
you want to bootstrap it but then make
as much money as possible quickly
if there's somebody who's in New York
who's who you want to go meet who's the
expert on something they're doing all
the high-end diagnostics for the New
York entrepreneurs the CEOs or big time
New York agent or whatever cool you
could drive to New York and you can you
could have your cameraman sit with you
you know when you drive to New York and
spend the night in a hotel and come back
like that's a couple hundred bucks right
plus gas and a little bit of food so it
doesn't have to cost a ton of money to
make that thing happen
um or you just go and run the same the
same model in New York you find 200 New
York video production companies I
message them and say I'm going to
interview this one person
can you come and film this for me and
I'll help you with your addiction and
like I'm giving you five thousand
dollars of value and here are the types
of people that I typically work with
and you'll get you'll get people who
will say yes most people just don't put
in enough for the effort right they'll
reach out to three people and never hear
back yeah so I guess it doesn't work I
did interview series like 10 years ago
where I I needed I wanted 10 guys so I
reached out to 60 and I got 28 so it was
better than I ever expected uh so I get
it I fully get I'm not afraid to reach
out I'll reach out to 500 whatever it
takes but I think that with the
addiction side of what it like like the
offering to help them with sugar or uh
you know weight loss or or alcohol
because I mean I can't tell you how many
weddings when I go to weddings people
somebody's always coming up to me from
like high school or something they're
drinking their head like how'd you quit
drinking what did you do like you go to
eight age like no I just quit so could
you but but if you want to go to a cool
whatever whatever works let's do it but
it's they're everywhere it's the point
of the story so that's how I got down
this path anyway
that's another great hack to find your
videographer look at who is doing
wedding videos Chicago wedding
videographers New York wedding
videographers because people who do
weddings yeah I don't hate weddings
for a course I created real estate I
hired a wedding video art like what is
the cheapest day of the week for me to
hire you because obviously you guys
don't shoot every day they were like
Tuesdays we will give you 300 for it was
four hours it was that was like 10 years
ago it was on Tuesdays I so you're 100
correct that is it was easy to find
yeah
yeah they hate their business it pays
them but they hate dealing with the
family who are crazy and want the world
and it's the same thing every day every
day every day you're actually giving
them some like something interesting to
film for their portfolio on just a
creative challenge again not everybody's
going to say yes but if you message 25
Chicago videographers who do wedding
stuff you'll get somebody who wants to
do your thing uh for free or in exchange
for some time with you yeah you know to
help them with their addiction problems
very very solid advice Evan thank you
and now you're showing up to do your
interview with a with a pro crew yeah
it's just yeah I uh
yeah I've had so much
so it's a pretty easy model right and
like we don't care how well the video
does it doesn't matter like we don't
want it to suck but you're a brand new
channel it's not gonna it's not gonna go
get a million views probably right
you'll take whatever comes in but the
Vita doesn't have to perform for you to
build a million dollar business the
relationships they're what's going to
actually help you build the business so
when you're interviewing high-end sports
agent or high-end uh MRT or whatever uh
diagnostic person you're asking about
them and how they got started and
getting access to them is pretty easy
because nobody asks them for interviews
if you need to talk to the athletes
that's a problem like LeBron is not
coming on your brand new show to talk
about performance and addiction
but an agent will because nobody cares
about the agent so getting access to
them is not hard so you you have them
come on the basic questions like how did
they get started and what do they see in
athletes or CEOs or entrepreneurs and
what do they believe will Peak
Performance and then you halfway through
transition it to you to say so I deal
with a lot of high performance and
addiction in particular so I have these
programs where I coach people for five
thousand dollars a month to get out of
their addiction what do you see in your
world of performance and how connected
addiction is to it yeah you need them to
know that you are an expert in addiction
you're not just some Larry King coming
in asking questions No Doubt
so inside the interview we have to talk
about addiction and frame it that you're
an expert in addiction
yeah and then business takes care of
itself
it's a fairly simple model
to run
it requires it requires a degree of
hustle to make it happen
compared to just you sit at home and you
make thought leadership videos and post
them and in a couple years you become
known for something
right
but what again back to the questions
that's a better strategy videos before I
start contacting people just thought
they were sum up because the page is
brand new I have it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
doesn't matter
like thinking about nobody's
interviewing these guys
we did this in Movie Makers um Ida I
don't know if you've met Ida yet I guess
since you're new maybe not but she did
it with um
one of the women who are on uh uh um
what's what's the show uh the Canadian
version of oh yeah Shark Tank dragon's
dead I did see that and so
brand new Channel Zero videos zero
subscribers reached out and said I'm
making a new channel talking about
blank which which connected to her thing
right and again nobody reaches out to
them
how big they are how whatever because
you never know because somebody at the
right moment what they're willing to do
I've realized that
just like that oh sure the people you're
reaching out to are not in demand from a
media perspective everybody wants to do
Partnerships with them everybody's
pitching them on their thing of course
that they want to sell nobody's asking
them for an interview you're gonna be
the only guy
and then you're the default guy that the
next time the sports agent has a athlete
with an addiction problem which is going
to be like a huge chunk of the athletes
who come through for sure
um or you know the liver is out of
control like you know what you should
talk to this guy Jim like they may have
somebody right now who they can pass out
to you that they don't know how to deal
with like the people got the high level
the test the diagnostic that's just a
teacher he just went for that because
that that is a great like people aren't
asking them for interviews and that's
that's the perfect place to find my
target
you don't need content on the channel
you can and every little bit of momentum
helps so maybe they go after like the
biggest agent you know having more
content and examples help but the people
you're talking to who you ideally want
like nobody's ever asked them for an
interview ever
you want to hear my story okay and it
helps promote their business and they
have content that they can use for their
social channels too um great that's
powerful that's good stuff yeah yeah
easy
it's easy for you to say yeah but it is
well listen I guess it's simple but it's
not easy but if you want to make twenty
thousand dollars as quickly as possible
that's the model because if if you ran
one show a week those are 50 people who
could refer ideal clients to you like if
50 people knew you who could work for
ideal clients to you your whole business
is taken care of you want to go more
aggressive do more than one a week do
three a week I just go
when I when I normally tell people this
idea I pitch them the idea of a of a
weekly show
so once a week a new Show's coming up of
you interviewing somebody it's a Biz Dev
show uh but if it were me I'd want to do
one a day
foreign
a day because then you get your you get
your clients by the end like I'm just
trying to figure out High scale as
quickly as possible how to find a camera
crew on it it takes you to a seven
figure business it's harder to build an
eight figure business off of that
strategy but it takes you a seven figure
business
and then that gives you the funds to do
all the other stuff to start building
the thought leadership content to work
on your courses your book all of that
other stuff for sure but uh
rolled out by the end of the week right
hey man it's only Monday Jim let's start
I've done some deadlines for myself
right now that's all I'm doing here uh
uh those people won't be very I love it
yeah that's the model
you got anything else quick in there oh
no or does that make sense
I mean a question about about
uh do you still use Evernote to keep
yourself in order because I like that's
where I I mean I'm not an organized
person like your video content for what
you're going to do do you use Evernote
still is that something you do
oh we still use that right now
everything we have like for me my team
we have uh 50 people now on the team and
Evernote is where we keep most of our
notes and planning
um there's other tools cool it's really
like the tool that you for sure use is
the one that's going to work for years
I've never used it but you know I've
been putting I I have you know 100
videos or more that I I would content
for a shoot that I I have ideas to shoot
so the ideas are easy I just want to
start to organize it and it's getting
out of control every time I go to write
the book or something I have a new idea
do something I want to get out there and
so uh I just want to start organizing it
before it gets further out of control
yeah when I'm when I'm uh filming videos
for example my team does most of the
work so like the research and the prep
and the the intros and anything I need
to know and every video is its own
Evernote note uh and then when I come to
film I just have to look at all those
notes instead of me having to like jump
between a bunch of emails or slack or
Facebook messages or whatever
um especially if it's just basic stuff
I'm sure if you were at a mega complex
uh
organization you might need something
more custom
but even for me with 50 people
where's the most people what what
department of your business do the is it
lower your concentration of people in
Eddie
oh yeah uh like content
whether it's editing research split
testing uh thumbnails like if you ask me
Jim how many people on my team I would
say 15.
it doesn't feel like we have 50 people
but then when we add it all up like oh
right yeah oh the Russian channel right
right right oh the Spanish Town Mara is
doing that oh yeah great yeah that has a
million subscribers you know all the
people who are working on my software
company and then and then all the split
testing because I don't deal with
everybody on a day to day
Nina my wife
she I see she runs the Navy and I run
the Navy Seals so I go fast and hard on
new projects uh and she manages the
operations of the existing projects
so I'm really tight with my core team or
whoever I'm subbing in for whatever
project we're working on right now and
then maybe they go back to the Navy and
work on like just the continuity of that
program
uh so yeah so it's mostly around content
but um I'm personally just working on
the new the new ideas
on that stuff but uh one thing at a time
well you're kind of doing it like this
is what again this is what I would do I
go in I try to see if I can figure
something out myself first and how
and then as soon as I figure it out
either I don't figure it out and drop
and go to something else or I figure it
out and then immediately delegate it out
like as soon as you start making you get
a single client in your five thousand
dollar business
uh per month then you hire an assistant
to do all the Outreach for you
because you you figured out the wording
in the language of how to get somebody
to come on your show
[Music]
through the Reps that you're putting in
and then you just train somebody like
here's here's now write this script and
copy and paste and now we're reaching
out to 2 000 people a month instead of
200. you just start to remove yourself
from all the stuff that you don't like
but you also kind of figure out along
the way to make it
to see me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I would always try to start with
the service instead of a product most
people who start with a product end up
getting screwed because the margins suck
on most products unless you go scale
meaning if you're gonna sell t-shirts
selling five t-shirts there's no margin
in it